what does willem dafoe from the
lighthouse say to a woman who has
recently engaged how long have you been
wearing that rock great great comedy
here we're gonna talk about the
lighthouse today by myself don't ask me
why well I'll tell you why John didn't
watch it
he left me abandon here the lighthouse
is a psychological horror film that
stars Batman in the Green Goblin it's
about two lighthouse keepers who slowly
descend into madness when a storm hits
the remote island they are stationed at
the film was directed by Robert Eggers
the director of the witch a film I
greatly appreciate it and it is written
by him and his brother Max and the film
is inspired by what goes on behind the
scenes at the real rejects someone asked
us on patreon recently do we
differentiate between what is a movie
and what is a film and for cases like
this I'd say yes this movie is
definitely more of a film this is cinema
this is not those theme parks that score
says he keeps talking about can't wait
for the Irishman keep a lookout for a
review next week it's produced by a 24
and if you're familiar with any of their
films you would know damn well you're
walking into some type of strange art
house
terror that would probably not be for
the masses I would see this being a
little bit more of a crowd splitter as a
film lover as a letter of film I think
there's so much to appreciate here it
takes place in the late 19th century so
Eggers opted to capture this film in
black and white and it's captured with a
ratio of a 1 to 19 to 1 1 by 19 by 1
1.19 by 1 119 by I thought it was 4:3
and it really helps with the immersion
of the experience in the overall time
period the phrase lived in keeps coming
to mind I would say the best way to
appreciate this movie would be in the
theatres I'm not sure how much you could
really appreciate this at home unless
you turned off all the lights in your
house and then the building in the
neighborhood and blasted the [ __ ] out of
your speakers but do keep in mind if you
when you go to the theaters it's only
gonna take up the center of whatever
screen you're watching at home and a
choice like this can sometimes feel like
pretentious or it can feel like a
gimmick like what I'm doing right now
but this wasn't the case for me when I
was watching it for me in an
hence the time period there are times
with the way they do just the overall
sound design of capturing the dialogue
or the surroundings the atmosphere and
the symmetry of the shots and it's
editing just the overall way this film
is composed it often feels like you're
watching a movie from many decades ago I
got the impression that a lot of the
calculated choices were based on the
question of how would they have captured
this scene or this moment way back when
I don't know if that's the case I just
sort of felt that way the modern-day
touches of the certain shots that
decided to get or certain editing
choices when it felt like out of a movie
from today it felt spare sin that
department and I think the
black-and-white elements really helped
to enhance the holo stark bleakness of
this experience of this journey that
these characters are on in a lot of ways
if they shot this in color
I think you've drastically would have
detracted and this movies pretty much
just two people Willem Dafoe and Batman
who develop and Robert Pattinson and
they are both undeniably absolutely
terrific here they both feel plucked out
of this time period this town is like a
great big chicken to get plucked
that's a censored line from Scarface
both of these roles are and I think the
word that's been going around like it's
a risk-taking roles they're incredibly
vulnerable daring poor trails and they
balance each other out perfectly I think
because of the rather bombastic
performance that Willem Dafoe gives a
lot of the electrifying praise of the
performer will be dished out to him
immediately the accident he does and
with the attention to detail they have
with the dialogue especially with his
character there were times early on
where I wished for sometimes I had a
thought of wow this really does sound
like it's from this time period
especially because I have no idea what
the hell he's talking about right now
overall though it's still able to absorb
this maddening performance he's so
off-putting in all the right ways and
there's such a lived-in history with his
portrayal and yeah I mean there's still
plenty of dialogue I did understand it
was enough for me to understand what was
going on and what he was really talking
about the Robert Pattinson well he
evidently has some very big moments in
the movie most of the film takes a much
more subtle approach with his character
Willem Dafoe he can kind of start he's
already a little bit crazy he's the
older man with a
more experience he's shepherding Robert
Pattinson and our paths as characters
still new to all this lighthouse work
the isolation of this job so I think
it's easy to look at the large grandiose
performance of Dafoe as the main
highlight but I and all honestly I think
they're both equal Patterson's is just a
lot more internal until the madness
overtakes them and a lot more becomes
external later on in the phone and I
genuinely love look love the music here
it's haunting harrowing unsettling it
feels classical horror when I was
jotting down some notes for this movie I
didn't watch a trailer I just listened
to the music the things that I really
really loved out of it was the mood the
tone and the pacing it's a slow build it
the movie really takes its time it has
some very deliberate pacing and it all
encapsulate s' this like dreadful eerie
grim filled ascent it requires a patient
viewer okay if you think you're walking
into it chapter 3 the st. the case
alright it's an ambitious story and
ambiguous tale and there's some very
clear mythological inspirations there's
evidently a lot of themes about power
and masculinity there's some very
evident HP Lovecraft inspirations and
for someone who has recently been
playing Call of Cthulhu and read shadow
over Innsmouth this year I really
appreciated that I mean the trailer
hints at some stuff yeah you see like a
little bit of this squid creature in
there I mean this movie has a lot of
strange surreal to put a plain and
simple frickin bizarre things that occur
some stuff can just be downright
unsettling and some of them is just
uncomfortable to watch all this which
can ultimately lead into many different
interpretations what this one was all
about it's been fun hearing what some
people think what every little nugget of
details about there are things I've
heard where I'm like oh I didn't pick up
on that at all but I could kind of see
your point and I appreciate that and to
sum it up I would say that this is a
film that I heavily appreciate it and
with happiness EDD I can't actually say
I love this movie I liked it and I
admired it so much yet there's just one
crucial thing and this is like the real
ticker for me it might sound odd
considering how much I praised the
performances of Pattinson and Dafoe it's
just
to put a plain and simple I couldn't
give two shits about them I don't think
characters I don't even think just like
the main character even necessarily
needs to be likable or relatable I don't
need a save the cat thing for every
movie but I generally felt too much of a
distance with these characters for my
personal taste above all else as a
viewer I need to feel truly invested in
at least one of these characters
especially to go on a journey like this
and for some reason I just didn't I
appreciate heavily the craft of this
film and the commitment of the performer
so much but I never felt invested or
connected to either one of them which I
ultimately think detracted from the
experience for me this movie's being
pitches of psychological horror film
maybe if I cared about the characters at
all I would have felt the perverse ID I
definitely felt the psychological
maddening side of it but it's not really
scary like it's scary in a different way
not your conventional nowadays
blockbuster horror movies it's a
different kind of scary but even giving
it that credit and with that perspective
because I wasn't really invested in them
I just I didn't really care what happens
to them in some ways I can see how my
gripe with that can be someone else's
reasoning for why this film works for
them so much for why they might love
this film and as I'm like coming me
anyway that's that's not the point of
the film and actually it's kind of the
point that there's a bit of a distance
or there's supposed to be more of an
observational pieces like I get it and I
would never try to sway someone away
from loving this movie for that
particular reason that's just my
personal opinion like for me it for this
to be for any movie for for it to be
something I love I got to be pretty
invested at least one of the characters
especially when watching like two people
on screen overall though I would still
give this something like a four out of
five when I first walked out it was more
like a three out of five of the movie
but it's definitely growing on me a lot
since I saw it a couple days ago there's
just way too much to appreciate here I
still think more movies like this
especially in the horror Department
should be getting made a lot more often
and I think there's plenty to consider
it come award season like even with the
script in and of itself I don't think
I've touched on it enough I know I
mentioned Willem Dafoe's dialogue I
really really appreciated how Earth
tick the dialogue sounded especially
because you know reading some HP
Lovecraft material New England
characters and stuff I was like this
feels like I'm reading that kind of book
again and those kind of characters or
speaking Zegers brothers really do have
a strong knack for authenticity of
dialog from time periods not of today
the music again is great the way it's
composed and shot is wonderful despite
me not really connecting with the
characters the performances are
brilliant everything from a technical
scale this is crafted beautifully and
more and more people should watch it
love to know what you guys thought of
this film did a little up to the hype
what's your interpretation of it leave a
comment below you guys can subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
well they get notified every time we got
a YouTube video up you could download
and follow us on the Stardust app
completely free to use we post daily
usually before we do an official YouTube
video review we got our opinion up there
first we do a lot of post therefore
things that we're not covering up on
YouTube lot of things we just catch up
on or whatever there's plenty of other
influencers who are over there you can
post your own reactions to so that link
is in the description box you have a
happy Halloween
you